uh let's go next to dave
from brooklyn dave from brooklyn you're
on the air
dave from brooklyn you're on the air
please unmute and we can chat
hey can you hear me yes i can hey um i'm
a big
big first time caller a big time fan
thank you video yesterday on youtube
about right-wing uh rash
uh radicalization and media and how
they're gonna keep one-upping each other
and so on and so forth
i was thinking about how as uh because i
have a few i come from a community
in los angeles a wealthier community
where most of my friends growing up
are trump supporters most of the family
members
that i have except for my parents are
trump supporters and so on and so forth
and
um i'm just baffled by
the fact that on the left we keep
fighting this we keep trying to fight
this fight where we
keep also trying to one-up each other
with our uh who's more correct who's
more
liberal who's more appropriate who's who
cares more about race who cares more
about
gender who cares more about all this
other stuff rather than getting things
done rather than having an
agenda that tries to actually
progressively pass
policies that will improve the lives of
americans well let's separate out some
of those because you know when you say
when you talk about who's most liberal
as an example
yeah there's no doubt that there is a
movement based around virtue signaling
gatekeeping
and litmus testing around what qualifies
you as being more liberal or liberal
enough and that's probably not a
productive movement
who's most correct to me does not sound
like it's under the same category
i think that that should be one of the
top priorities let's figure out
what is most correct what policies are
actually the
most useful and beneficial so i don't
know that i'd wrap all of that together
necessarily
maybe i wasn't using my words actually
but i meant the reason why i
uh thought about this is because when it
came to this whole gamestop
fiasco with all the uh with robin hood
and everything that's going on i have a
lot of friends on the left who are
really they're really have they're
really upset about what's going on when
they don't really understand the
what's going on on the back end i have
friends or engineers at robin hood my
wife's an engineer at a financial
company i used to be a software engineer
myself
and you know from a technical
perspective there are of course
somewhat corrupt things going on at a
higher level but from a technical and
financial perspective it makes a lot of
sense what these companies have done
um from a policy perspective and and
shutting down trading at least in the
beginning
and they know when we come and we get
all mad about it when we're not really
educated as a as a liberal populist like
the entire
left-wing majority we're not all
educated on what goes on in the back end
no that's certainly true and i've read
some of the technical defenses of why
uh why the ability to purchase was
curtailed or suspended but
if that is i i i what my position after
reading more about it
is that if that if we have a system in
which that is what is the correct
technical decision
then there's a broader problem with the
system that needs to be solved and
listen
there's a noise coming through on your
end that's so bad i'm gonna have to let
you go
but i really do appreciate the question
and it's
it's an important issue uh for sure and
one
one which we will we will continue
looking at uh very strongly